las negociaciones entre londres y
bruselas sobre el protocolo de irlanda
del norte están en un punto muerto en el
que ninguna de las partes quiere
negociar de hecho la ministra de
exteriores británica liz tras quienes
además la negociadora en este asunto ha
dado un ultimátum a la unión europea o
hace las modificaciones solicitadas al
protocolo o de lo contrario presentará
la legislación interna que sea necesaria
para romper ese protocolo según el
telegraph que es un periódico muy
cercano al gobierno la ministra habría
dado un plazo de 72 horas pero lo cierto
es que la unión europea no va a ceder en
repetidas oportunidades ha dejado en
claro que tanto el brent como el
protocolo fueron negociados y firmados y
no habrá cambios lo cierto es que el
gobierno británico tiene afán y ahora
mucha presión política para lograr esas
modificaciones dado que los unionistas
en irlanda del norte que ya perdieron el
poder histórico político por más de 100
años con los republicanos del sinn fein
se niegan a formar el ejecutivo si no
hay esas modificaciones
declaración enviada por el ministerio de
exteriores sobre esta llamada que tuvo
la ministra británica con el
vicepresidente de la unión europea se
exponen los siguientes puntos la
situación en irlanda del norte es una
cuestión de paz y seguridad interna para
el reino unido- y si la unión europea no
muestra la flexibilidad necesaria para
ayudar a resolver estos problemas
entonces como gobierno responsable no
tenemos más remedio que actuar y así el
reino unido- entonces advierte de los
pasos siguientes lo que prosigue en esta
larga discusión entre londres y bruselas